well Donny has always been so special to
us I mean he's got an enthusiasm that
you really can't find anywhere else he
said you think you've got problems you
know and then you see little Donny and
what he has to deal with and the way
he's just always so full of joy and
happiness and he's so open to people it
really puts things in perspective
Oh Danny's great very bright sometimes
it gets a little sad when he sees the
kids out on the playground he's stuck
inside but generally he's a really
healthy
Donny has more heart than most athletes
twice the size I just went down need to
be happy to find somebody who loved him
you know to be able to fit in with
everybody else I guess what that one for
Donny is is freedom to just be a normal
kid and I'll do anything I can to just
help him to get through life without the
disability infringing on his ability to
enjoy life this holiday season the
little Donny Foundation is asking for
your support with your financial help we
hope to cure little Donny disease before
another child like little Donny becomes
afflicted with the penis the size of a
horses
[Music]
Donnie is the first documented case of
what we have labeled magnimous oblivia
phallus itís in layman's terms that is
having an enormous penis which you are
unaware of yeah
so I just want to show you some of the
safety devices I've developed a little
Donnie helping lead a more normal life I
have to say that I don't like these
devices I think they call attention to
his disease I think they make him feel
different and you know his penis is
really not that big all right honey his
penis accounts for over thirteen percent
of his total body work hey you know what
we don't need to talk about Donnie we're
going to show these guys some of the
devices I've developed for you know what
as successful as I would have hoped yeah
I call a penis strip and it caused some
chafing to really get it to hold the
penis down okay okay wait buddy I get it
I gotta get him
Doni really likes chocolate milk I love
little Donny cuz he always comes by and
visits or less sick kids sometimes I
can't breathe or keep any food down
but when little Donny comes by he dances
and I just laugh if I do not die I want
no Donny at my birthday party and it's
big penis too
we could laugh a lot and then we could
have cake I guess this Donny's in for
some tests
I don't know these kid of wish kids are
all the same the probably most from this
they feel sorry for themselves so I just
trying to shake him up a little bit you
know snap him out of it
help I don't know what's the matter with
this kid is there someone in here
feeling sorry for themselves Oh Donny
but the tank was vacant I spilled one
little creamier
I'm afraid gently and a pussy's worst
nightmare are you Donny yeah
what's so bad that you're what the hell
is dark oh that's his condition sir he
has enormous penis but he's unaware of
it oh yeah well you know we're gonna do
we're gonna turn negative into a
positive
get up Donny come over here come on
let's go you know what's your jump
between your legs you got a magnificent
god-given weapon that's what your head
study come on oh yeah these might see
Barry we done there hey like come on I
tackled nothing no man
we were on our final performance at city
centre and when we were doing our finale
some of the dancers noticed some
movement in in the auditorium and before
we knew it this young man Donnie and
rose out of his seat and was in the
aisles dancing and creating such an
incredible vocabulary of movement that
it was so much more inspiring than the
work we were doing on stage fortunately
for us he came backstage after the show
we asked him to come join us in some of
our rehearsals and we've just received a
new grant which were in rehearsal for a
new piece which is being inspired by
Donnie's movement and his freedom it's
astonishing we don't know much about the
disease but what what we do know is that
it has more than likely mostly to do
with genetics as opposed to something
that may have gone wrong in a delivery
room the little Donnie Foundation was
formed in 1992 by an international team
of doctors and scientists including
myself who shared a passion for little
Donnie's penis now since then many
surprising discoveries have been made
but unfortunately a cure has yet to be
found with the enzymes we pulled out of
little Donnie's penis we were able to
develop a rocket fuel with 38% increased
efficiency
[Music]
you